[Music]  [Music]  this is our best chance to find a  habitable planet  we breed and raise our own crew three  [Music]  train them in isolation to prepare them  for life and space  two the voyage will take 86 years  i'm scared of what  there's nothing to be scared of  are the link between past and future  generations  and have been entrusted with the  survival of our species normal kids  sensitive and smart i need to protect  them  there's a toxin in the water it's coming  from us  we're eating something toxic  it's the blue it's  to decrease pleasure  i'm not drinking it what does it feel  like to feel something  [Applause]  i  restarting  about everything he can't  protect you protect  [Music]  i'm scared there's nothing to be scared  [Music]  [Music]  you